traveling with little kids already hard
enough we've all done that but
the onerous coveted mandates have made
it a complete nightmare for some
families
take the kimballs just days ago they
were kicked off a
spirit airlines flight because their
four-year-old son
carter was not wearing a mask carter is
non-verbal with
autism the family even had a medical
note stating that carter was exempt
from mass mandates due to his condition
but that didn't matter
carter and his father were removed from
the flight anyway
carter's parents callie and cameron
kimball join me now
um thank you for being here cameron as i
understand this the airline has
reimbursed you
um but did they offer any other form of
apology
or explanation no not at all
they uh they refunded 180
of so maybe 25 percent of their total
ticket
plus nothing towards having to get home
on the american airlines flight
what happens when your son has a mask
placed on his face if you've ever tried
it oh so that's what i was fighting them
about
was so he has spd like uh sensory
disorders
and he's very much autistic um
and he just freaks out like he
he just doesn't understand and he has
little meltdowns
and yeah he'll just
the panic will cause him to go into
those meltdowns that you saw in the
video and he'll harm himself
um so that's what we're just trying to
avoid because once he gets on the plane
he's fine
he loves airplanes more than anything
he's actually running around the room
flying them right now
callie you weren't on the plane but as a
mom
um and as someone who you know you you
you deal with you know difficult
circumstances often
um and when oh there he is oh
oh i just want to i just want to play
with him now i just want to like hang
out with you guys
i forgot i was doing the show for a
second but callie
to me his reaction is actually a normal
reaction right it's
it's being as a child being constrained
by a mask
is tough to do for any child but how
does this make your family feel that
apparently
you're not going to be able to travel
under certain circumstances i guess
there will be an exemption coming
forward
by the federal government and some
period of time
for cases like this but are you supposed
to not travel
on a plane well not traveling for us
that's not an option
um you know cameron is from utah and i
am from arkansas
and our families live on opposite sides
of the country hence
why he was there in the first place um
we have actually flown spirit
pretty much every single time that we've
flown because it was
inexpensive it was you know kid-friendly
and they never had an issue with his
mask we went to las vegas
twice last year during the orlando as
well
and we went we took him to nasa of
course you know we all wore our masks we
you know everyone was safe
but carter can't and we
honestly like not traveling didn't even
come across my mind like ever
until this whole issue
let me understand this cameron were
other passengers complaining
to your knowledge um so there's a lot of
other passengers that stood up for us
um but there's no one really complaining
about him
like um one of the things i was talking
with our attorney about was
we went to the front like the front desk
where you have to talk to someone from
spirit to check your bag
no one said anything you go through the
airport go through security
no one says anything he's running around
in front of the gate
no one says anything there was just one
lady in particular right at the gate
that just
did not apparent but apparently these
rules don't apply to the biden
administration
you saw john kerry climate czar he was
on the plane
with uh without a mass but he was just
eating although it didn't look like he
was eating right there
um exactly well it's very curious we're
not we're not understanding what
happened here but
it's just completely unacceptable cali
and cameron i hope you get to travel and
i hope
i hope your son gets to travel and and
comfort and
this is absurd thank you so much for
being here tonight